alles neu bei der spd aktuell olaf
scholz der soll der kanzler werden und
die spd-führung die wird auch neu
aufgestellt nachdem walter borjans
gesagt hat er will nicht mehr lars
klingbeil soll neuer spd boss werden
zusammen mit saskia esken soll er die
partei weiter führen und darüber
sprechen wir hier im studio was bedeutet
das für die spd was bedeutet das für
deutschland dass lars klingbeil antritt
bei uns im studio power uns sagen wir du
kennst ihn ja besser als viele andere
journalisten besser als alle anderen die
gerade zu hause unser programm verfolgen
erst mal ganz schnell
charakterisiert diesen mann lars
klingbeil was macht ihn aus lars
klingbeil wurde lange als zu ruhig
verspottet als jemand der gar nicht
general kann weil er nicht drauf haut
aber er hat es geschafft ist der
architekt des spd war sie geworden
ärzteschaft auch gegen widerstände zum
beispiel eine agentur durchzudrücken
moderne dinge durchzudrücken zu sagen
nein wir machen das jetzt so und er hat
das vertrauen von olaf scholz bekommen
deswegen war in wahrheit während des
wahlkampfs schon so etwas wieder geheime
chef ihnen hat man gesehen die anderen
beiden saskia esken und norbert walter
borjans er nicht so und er hat es
geschafft jetzt zu einem der wichtigsten
männer der spd zu werden nach olaf
scholz möglicherweise dann jetzt der
wichtigste das geöffnete es ist
angesprochen wie glaubst du wie wird
dieses duo funktionieren wir verstehen
sich denn die beiden die beiden
verstehen sich ok würde ich sagen also
es ist keine große liebe aber es ist
eine vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit auch
er war ja derjenige der damals den
prozess gestaltet hat als general man
muss sich das so vorstellen der asche
unter martin schulz generalsekretär dann
war martin schulz weg lars klingbeil
blieb andrea nahles kam lars klingbeil
blieb und dann kam das neue duo und lars
klingbeil blieb auch damals hat er mit
sich gehadert hat gedacht geht das gut
kann ich mit den beiden weiter general
sein aber er hat durchgehalten und wurde
belohnt zuletzt hat er und hat natürlich
auch in der spd mann darüber nachgedacht
ob er nicht doch minister werden müsste
er kommt aus einer soldaten familie bei
münster geboren soltau ist das und da
haben viele darüber nachgedacht muss so
ein mann der das im blut hat sozusagen
nicht verteidigungsminister werden aber
auch für olaf scholz dem spd-chef ist es
wichtig dass lars klingbeil
dem kanzlerkandidaten und kommt dem
kanzler ist es wichtig dass lars
klingbeil spd chef wird weil er so ein
realo ist er gehört zu den see heimat er
ist kein verrückter linke das war früher
mal als er mit rock gitarre in den
bundestag in so ungefähr aber jetzt ist
er jemand der den laden zusammenhalten
soll also diejenigen die da rein
gekommen sind auch die jusos er kann gut
mit kevin kühnert macht einmal in der
woche eine art install mit ihm hat den
auch eingebunden also wenn es einer
schafft diese wilde truppe
zusammenzuhalten das klingt war der
einzige der mit olaf scholz und mit
kevin kühnert kann der muss es jetzt
machen paul der spd chefsessel der galt
mal als nicht besonders beliebt ja dabei
wusste man wenn man auf dem sessel lande
da bist du in drei vier monaten schon
wieder weg das hat sich ja offenbar
gewandelt ist das wieder richtig
attraktive posten geworden spd chef es
ist einer der attraktivsten posten immer
noch den man bekommen kann denn was
viele nicht wissen nehmen wir an ist
klappt mit der ampel und olaf scholz
wird kanzler dann sitzt lars klingbeil
dann sitzen lars klingbeil und saskia
essen bei allen wichtigen entscheidungen
dabei wer wird minister die beiden
entscheiden mit was ist bei einer
koalitions nacht wir erinnern uns an
diese
koalitionsausschusses von angela merkel
da sitzen die parteichefs am tisch das
heißt man hat viel mehr
durchsetzungskraft vielmehr macht am
ende als als einzelner minister und das
ist natürlich eine große aufgabe man
darf nicht vergessen das klingt weil es
gerade mal anfang 40 also der hat schon
eine wahnsinns karriere da hingelegt was
erwartest du welche schwerpunkte könnte
er setzen
lars klingbeil wird versuchen die
realistische politik weiter
voranzutreiben er ist jemand habe ich
gerade gesagt der aus münster kommt eine
soldaten familie das ist keiner der in
der vogue blase irgendwo herum schwirrt
sondern jemand der versteht auch was die
leute aus den ländlichen regionen bewegt
er hat seinen wahlkreis zweimal mit ganz
ganz hohen prozentpunkten gewonnen mit
die höchsten die es in deutschland gab
nach einer zweitplatzierter in diesem
fall und er ist jemand der versuchen
wird die spd nah bei den menschen zu
halten wie man immer gesagt hat in der
vergangenheit was so ein bisschen
verloren gegangen ist das wird seine
wichtigste aufgabe sein und dann wird er
sicherlich versuchen erst seeheimer also
gehört er zur konservativen richtung der
spd diese position mit durchzudrücken
aber was ich gerade gesagt habe das
wichtigste für ihn wird sein die partei
zusammenzuhalten denn wir wissen ja alle
olaf scholz ist nicht der beliebteste
man in der spd das heißt er muss
sozusagen die politik von olaf scholz
immer wieder übersetzen in die partei
damit da nicht zur explosion kommt und
man muss eins sagen paul er ist jemand
der sich keiner diskussion verweigert
hatte er auch immer wieder bei uns sich
harten fragen gestellt hat einen harten
fragen gestellt hat und er ist einer der
lacht er auch mal ein schalk im nacken
hat hoffen wir dass er uns mit beidem
erhalten bleibt also die heftigen
diskussionen zu stellen und eben auch
weiterhin lacht wenn er dann spd-chef
wird danke für deinen besuch heute paul
ronzheimer hier im studio